um
what is it
it is a stapler
what's it do
there is a tube
and a slide where individual pieces of
metal are pushed forward
and then punched
into the paper
and voila
they're held fast
right
and that's it
worst part of my job is when a baby gets
stuck inside a woman and i have to go in
sometimes elbow deep turn their head and
shoulders and pull it out jesus i do not
know this
and as i'm not a vet never having
children never hence the mother of
invention
i have invented
another sex
in labor
so much of a woman's life is wasted
being tied into and out of our dresses
as i tell my girls this time could be
spent reading writing painting indeed
oh
it is merely two strips of material
treated with tree sap that runs the
length of the garment
and off please
it is brilliant katya velcro but let me
consider the unseen ramifications
and many rapes
i call it
the exaltation
sounds promising
it is to be four stories high 70 feet
wide one climbs this ladder to the cart
it seats for men or women yes women
should ride it too
as well as children wonderful
now gravity and the parabolic form give
us the momentum for an upward push then
[Applause]
how do they not die
they do
but that is the point of the exaltation
the journey ends in the inescapable
conclusion
death
what the old the infirm terminally ill
the suicidal the board
have one final moment of sky and sun
before crashing to their death
we shall go with
the stapler
bravo
we've embossed it yeah
take great part of it
congratulations
[Music]